[Music]
the pandemic shuts down schools around
the world
and in some countries they are now
reopening
like here in brazil and it's a relief
for parents
i was barely able to take care of my kid
next to running the household and
going to work i didn't want to lose my
job as so many others did in the
pandemic
but what about the children can they
catch up with what they've missed
how long will classes go on for this
time or
will there be new disappointment with
schools soon forced to close again
as new virus variants spread
welcome to your grove at 19 special i'm
chris colburn berlin
summer holidays are over and school is
starting again in many parts of germany
for the second time kids will take up
their classes under the conditions of
the pandemic
many fear that this school year will be
just
as chaotic as the last when
homeschooling took place for weeks on
end where does the country stand today
and have preparations been taking place
over the holidays
our reporter went to find out
the final touch for the school opening
here at this primary school in schwerina
northern germany
last preparations are underway the
decorations are ready
but other things are still a long way
off the online learning platform for
example
here two preparations have started but
the platform won't be ready when the
students are back at school
we're looking at what is possible for
now we have formed a task group that
deals with the platform intensively
they are consulting on a regular basis
they will try to answer questions like
how can we use it for our purposes
how can we make it accessible to parents
as well as children
one thing is ready the antigen rapid
test
twice a week the children are tested for
covet 19 with the help of their teachers
otherwise the same measures as last year
apply
for the first two weeks the children
will have to wear face masks
in the entire school building and also
during class
when they're outside they can take them
off but we also have to air the
classroom every 20 minutes
at least three to five minutes
airing the rooms another measure that
hasn't changed since last year
additional air filters or purification
systems have not been installed
open windows and doors ought to be
enough
we have no problem whatsoever with the
ventilation the children have their
jackets with them
they can take them on and off again
that's totally fine
the parent's representative disagrees he
wants air filters
especially for elementary schools we
called for purification systems 12
months ago precisely to protect the
weakest of society
those who cannot be vaccinated children
under the age of 12.
unfortunately that didn't happen we're
exactly at the same level as last year
and that's not good
in germany covet infections are rising
again
yet everybody hopes that students will
be able to come to school for as long as
possible let's talk more about this with
david evans he's a senior fellow at the
center for
global development working on education
health
and social safety nets welcome to dw
david
distance learning has surged during the
pandemic
what does a successful concept for
distance learning look like
on the whole distance learning during
the pandemic has not been a great
success but if we think about successful
distance learning we have to think about
what
good teaching and learning look like in
general students need interaction with
skilled and motivated teachers that's
what they need when they're
in school in person and if we want any
positive results from distance learning
we have to replicate those principles
even in high income countries for the
first months of shutdown most education
was
totally asynchronous teachers would send
some materials home and students would
do the work
over time these high income environments
were able to move to
distance learning which was which much
better replicated
good teaching uh during a non-pandemic
where
teachers were actually interacting with
students
so technology seems to be playing
a an important role here uh for
students and teachers to communicate
with each other despite not being
in the same room so one would assume
that
countries that can provide this
technology advanced countries
can also provide the best distance
learning concept is that correct
so this is absolutely true in high
income countries what you've seen is
classes using things like zoom and
google classroom
where teachers are able to interact with
students in most low-income countries
what this distance learning has looked
like
has been much more like maybe a radio
program or a television program once a
day
and if you can imagine trying to learn
calculus or physics from a radio show
it's just very difficult to
to imagine now there have been some
exceptions so in a middle-income country
like botswana
teachers were called upon to call
students
primary school students to help them
work through mathematics problems
and we saw significant learning gains
amongst those students relative to
students who
who didn't have access to that so there
are alternatives in places where there
isn't strong
internet and zoom setups but it is a
huge
challenge so we see all the best efforts
from all sides here
in order to create a learning
environment for students
but still there are studies that show
remote students are more stressed than
their peers in the classroom
why is that so
we see these students they don't have
the opportunity to
interact with other students they don't
have the opportunities to relax between
classes and beyond that what we've seen
even in high income countries as you say
with the best efforts
what we see is over the course of the
last year with distance learning
the very the highest income students in
high income countries haven't seen much
learning loss relative to other years
but lower income students in even in
high income countries where
there's all this technology available
haven't had
uh haven't had the same learning gains
we've seen significant learning loss
the reason for that is that those
students well normally they be in school
and a teacher could help
supervise and their peers could help
encourage those students are sitting at
home
maybe staring at a laptop and the
students who have
fewer resources often also have parents
who
don't have the flexibility to work from
home and to provide them supervision and
support
to keep them focused on school during
the school day
now speaking of learning loss children
are missing
school in latin america for example 160
days almost on average during the first
year of the pandemic
what impact is this having on a
generation of students
the impact is enormous so in some
countries the amount of schooling that
students lost
have lost has amounts to a large part of
the schooling that they'd be expected to
receive
over the course of their entire lifetime
in chad
sudan south sudan children have lost
more than 10 percent of
all the education that they'll be
expected to have
over their entire lives now this
translates into not only a loss of
learning
but a loss of incomes and a loss of
opportunities
for individuals and families and in
terms of economic growth looking forward
and how are societies going to be able
to offset this impact
so there are some countries that have
started to invest
in bringing children back up to speed so
we have proven strategies
of targeting children who've fallen
behind especially these lower income
students who have had fewer resources
during the pandemic
so the uk has is rolling out a
large-scale tutoring program
we have evidence from countries like
donna and india
from the past from before the pandemic
that this kind of targeted tutoring
either with tutors after school or with
teaching assistants during the school
day
can really bring students who who have
fallen behind
back up to speed and we need to see this
all over the world
so face-to-face teaching is the key
being in the classroom or remote david
evans of the
center for global development thank you
for your thoughts
time now for your questions about the
coronavirus pandemic
and it's over to our science
correspondent derek williams
i was vaccinated a few days ago my arm
didn't hurt and i didn't have any side
effects
is that normal i talked a lot here about
vaccine side effects so it's great to
hear from someone
who had none because that's actually
really
common um i haven't been vaccinated yet
but among
friends and family who have i'd say
roughly
half told me they didn't notice a thing
afterwards although the statistics will
vary
from from vaccine to vaccine it looks
like
for most of them at least a third of all
recipients don't report even the mildest
of side effects like like injection site
pain or
or a little bit of swelling there's no
way to predict in advance
exactly how you'll react but but experts
say
two factors clearly increase the
likelihood that you'll feel
some kind of discomfort after getting a
shot
the first is your sex um recent cdc
data shows that around four out of five
reports of covid vaccine side effects
have come from women which doesn't come
as a surprise really since that's also
been observed in the past
with many other types of vaccine a
number of
of biological and and possibly even
social reasons
seem to contribute to to that phenomenon
the second factor that plays a role is
your age
younger people are a lot more likely to
report
side effects than those over 55 which is
another result backed up by experience
with past vaccines the theory there
is that's because the immune response in
general
declines with age so in a nutshell
having few or no side effects after
being vaccinated
isn't particularly rare and apparently
even less so uh if you're like me a man
who's no longer a spring chicken
[Music]
and before we go the chinese city of
wuhan is where the pandemic began
and now the delta variant has
authorities they're worried as a result
wuhan has launched another
city-wide coronavirus testing campaign
after a small
cluster of the variant was identified on
monday
juan had previously reported no locally
transmitted cases
for more than a year
that's our show thanks for watching see
you back here tomorrow until then
stay safe
you